the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we've become to top it up that I
think you know feels like including what
almost the chorus technology might be
about which is personality why are
something easy person person why we like
something why did you around us behave
finally supportively or loyalty or
whatever so what can we understand our
personality scientifically so how do
psychologists I study in some systematic
fashion some key concepts so finding our
traits States and contexts traits I'll
come to these and then finally some
brain correlates personality so I love
this quote because I think it's a about
individuality which says every person is
in certain respects like all other
people and we think that's true there's
something deeply similar among all
humans also about psychology also about
our brains like some other people that
is there's dimensions of individuality
or like some other people like if we're
a male or a female if we're this age of
that age this culture or that culture
like math or don't like math you know
like vanilla ice cream or don't like ice
cream right and then finally we come
down to the unique set of things that
make you you and that's that that's very
hard to study the unique things that
make you you but the second level
dimensions of individuality we can study
in personality is obviously a big one
that we feel in our own lives and around
us so you know this is the old original
Star Trek alright
like many programs or in TV series it
plays out really is in part as you go
from galaxy to galaxy and then struggle
with various uh opponent civilizations
but uh it almost always comes down to a
personality thing right the Captain Kirk
who's has to be aggressive and charge in
there and do something very emotional
Spock who's the pure rational machine
and a Koi who represents a sort of
humane touch as opposed to the rational
thought and somewhere in between as the
man who has to pick the action to
command the ship right so it's all every
show plays out with
I'm asking him to be human right and who
asking him to be rational and him you
know killing somebody who's
troublemaking right okay so so what do
we mean by personality a set of
behavioral emotional and cognitive
tendencies that people display over time
when we talk about personality right we
really mean something that we think is
consistent in ourselves and other
people's that somebody is shy
somebody's helpful somebody's rude and
across situations not just one place one
time but pretty regularly and that
varies across people that distinguishes
them from one to another something
that's kind of you know there's some
similarities but people vary in this and
so when people think about this they
think in three categories as it
conceptualize that one is traits by
trait we mean something that that's in
you that's constant across situations
and times and but we also think of it as
a continuum so for example if we talk
about introversion extroversion or
outgoingness and shyness it's not that
everybody's one or the other along that
path from being extremely shy to
extremely outgoing many of us are
somewhere in between and then we can
talk about states how we are temporarily
you know how do we feel excited afraid
that kinds of stuff and then situations
were in because they're specific at
times and places and that influences we
get we're fearful we're happy we're
looking forward to something we're not
looking forward to something so these
are different pieces that might end up
in how we feel inside and how we act on
the world so here's a very funny thing
because it's a very different line of
research than practically anything else
that's out there very active because
we're so curious about personality
here's how people have basically
approached it not everybody but the sort
of the mainline scientific perspective
they looked in the dictionary and
originally in the 1930s for this line of
work and they said let's look at all the
adjectives in the dictionary that we
think might describe personality in some
sense so here's you know they would look
up they found nearly 18,000 words in the
dictionaries that seem to be adjectives
for describing people and something that
might be about personality whether
you're affable or amiable
congenial convivial cordial friendly
genial sociable welcoming these are all
synonyms right right they don't mean
roughly this roughly the same thing we
think but they found it you know you
know 18,000 terms are because we think a
lot about other people and talk a lot of
other people and other people are
interesting to us and as I said we're
not going to study you know 18,000
dimensions of personality especially
when lots of them overlap like this so
what we're going to do is see are there
some underlying traits a manageable set
of personality traits or dimensions that
many of these 18,000 adjectives sort of
boiled down to so manageable set of
personally dimensions so how do people
measure personality in some way and for
those of us who like to measure things
by behavior you do a test or you push a
button or we measure your brain
personality research is always funny
because the bulk of it these people's
self-report about themselves and about
the last thing most of us in psychology
trust these people's reports about
themselves ok so what we think is for
many reasons that we can talk about a
little bit what we think is you know
that that people when they fill out a
piece of paper describing themselves
they start to have all kinds of thoughts
like okay I'm not going but compared to
who I'm you know I might do I want to
fill this out like I really like to
think about myself or how I think I
really am or and I sometimes this way
and sometimes that way which is the
right answer okay so all these things
bother us as researchers but we don't
have a more direct path towards
personality so we can interview people
about you know their personality we can
observe I'll talk about some studies
that involve observation but by far the
dominant mode of collecting somewhat
quantitative data of our personality our
questionnaires of the kind you just got
handed out to you thank you teller and
the most famous one of all which you
have in your hands is this so-called Big
Five personality dimensions there's many
other aspects of personality we'll talk
about that but this is the most famous
one and it was derived in some sense
objectively and empirically from factor
analysis like this what they said is we
have this huge number of terms but many
of them are either very similar to one
another or when we call Antiqua
they're sort of opposites so for example
if a person's rude are we also likely to
think of them as kind now you could have
something you know there's many movies
of the rude senior citizen who turns out
to be you know have a heart of gold
underneath right every year we we have
all kinds of but in general if you say
this person's rude usually doesn't go
and they're so kind right we think of
them as sort of opposites in personality
if somebody's dependable or carefree now
maybe you know somebody's both
dependable and carefree but we tend to
think carefully people are not so
dependable they can be delightful right
dependable people but now rude you can
be dependable and rude or dependable and
polite right okay so you get a feeling
of that so they had people fill out tons
of pieces of paper saying how do they
feel these factors describe them and
they started with this huge universe of
terms and then they try to boil it down
and boil it down and boil it down by
looking at all this doesn't show up very
well this as well correlations you have
the notes so you can guess without being
able to see you can guess let's pick two
things if I pick the adjectives carefree
and dependable kind of go together and
not go together doesn't tend to go
together and people describing
themselves how about hard-working and
dependable kind of goes together okay
see how so they they said we can take a
lot of these adjectives and say piles in
them going one area we'll just pick a
few words to describe that dimension
piles of them go in another area and
they boil it down basically to two by
factor analysis and they end up with
five big factors in this most widely
used one so here's two of them and here
comes a big thing they have the factor
which is basically just mathematically a
set of adjectives that travel together
that are highly correlated when people
describe themselves alright and are
somewhat anti-correlated or uncorrelated
with the other dimensions that's purely
empirical now though they have the set
of adjectives like carefree or
dependable not hard-working okay or
hard-working and now they have to say
what's the label I'm going to put on the
dimension of human personality there's
no science for that that's judgment but
five of them get fixed and once these
got fixed they've become the terminology
of the field all right so they said
we're going to call one
conscientiousness those are people who
say they're not carefree they are
dependable and they are hard-working
does that make sense
or somebody's agreeable that's one of
the other big five separate five is
somebody says I'm pretty compliant I'm
pretty kind and I'm seldom rude so I'm
going to give you a minute to try this
you can fill it out fully so your piece
of paper that you have is a version of
this test it's the real thing
one side tells you how to score it don't
look at that okay the other side at the
bottom the other side so just try a few
items for fun if you feel like it and
you can fill it out later and score
yourself or print it out from the notes
and score your friends respond use it
responsibly the knowledge or yeah and
and you could just have an intuition of
what does it mean because it's almost
all personality research almost all of
it does exactly what you're doing now
which is gives you a piece of paper and
have you describe yourself to yourself
I'll give you a minute just to get a
feeling for you it I think it's kind of
fun and the feeling you get like add
some people worry about stuff like who
are you comparing yourself to if you're
outgoing compared to who you know
compared to Robin Williams okay maybe
not so much sure you know compared to
your roommate maybe yes right so all
these questions like you know where do
you get these number from how do you
come to these answers and so on people
worry about polishing your image oh yes
I'm always polite you know I'm nearly
perfect when I'm asked to describe
myself okay to the extent that people
did that it wouldn't work right because
everybody would look perfect all the
time
so so these big five are OSHA are
openness conscientiousness extraversion
agreeableness and neuroticism and for
memorizing for tests Oshin is the
acronym okay these were the ones that
have come out as as five separable
dimensions that seem to cover a
tremendous amount of individual
descriptions of human personality and
are widely used in research so here's
your big five inventory here's the other
on the backside how to score it if you
feel like figuring out what this test
would say about yourself okay you could
be honest with your scoring because you
write is we're not going to collect it
it's just you describing you to yourself
if you're curious and now I'm going to
go on and you know you're more than
welcome to finish it whenever you want
it's thus yours to keep and here's how
we would score it where you would score
it you know it tells you in the bottom
what to do so a person who for
conscientiousness and we'll come back to
this is a really interesting measure and
if you rate yourself as somebody who
does a thorough job as a reliable worker
persevere until the task is finished
does things efficiently and makes plans
and follows through with them the higher
you rate yourself on those this makes
sense you're more conscientious right
the less you say that you're you're
somewhat careless you tend to be
disorganized you tend to be lazy and
you're easily distracted well those are
negative things for that dimensions that
make sense okay so you have to watch
when you score at which are the positive
in which are the negative
as you square them up which hit a plus
or a minus and they try to make it
either way so that if you constantly say
yes you know you're not going to score
anything that makes sense even to
yourself okay anyway so here's the big
questions right okay all this sort of
research behind of this factor analysis
you want to know two things are they
stable do they really describe a person
across situations in time that's what we
mean by personality and second do they
protect behaviors and life outcomes is
there something about them that goes
with things that we care about variably
across people so where people have
looked at this over some number of years
it correlates 0.5 to 0.7 across 30 or 40
years of life height and sex to think
about it correlates point-four so it's
again height and sex is kind of it
people will pick that to think about on
average men tend to be taller than women
but lots of women are taller than lots
of individual men okay so it's stronger
relationship across time it's more
stable than what you'd predict by height
and sex and here's something really
interesting they tested people across
seven years with in childhood with in
young adulthood within the 30s or even
50 to 70 age range and here's something
kind of striking if you test people
twice across seven years starting from
you know infancy as best you can or
questions about them because they can't
fill out forms to adulthood the striking
thing is that the older you get the more
consistent you become across a seven
year period the older you get the more
consistent you become so how might you
interpret that there's a couple
different ways you could think about
that the older you become the more
consistent you become in describing your
personality let's pretend your
descriptions are accurate the more
consistent your personality is how do
you think about the expect that is that
what you expect something opposite yeah
yeah so there's two ways to describe
getting older yeah yeah so like me yeah
I get set in my ways right yes okay
sorry go or I'll say the other way we
discovered the ways that we really like
okay I'm again yeah my friend Robert
Sapolsky at Stanford who writes
fantastic books and was a fantastic
lecturer had an essay where he said he
noticed it is you know late 40s or 50s
that the people is working lab that they
were playing irritating music I was just
bothering him when they were playing the
music and it was music you know the
people of your generation listened to
okay I said why is it irritating because
you know he played his when he played
the Beatles or whatever they were
irritating to his parents okay so what's
what's going on and he said oh and so he
did a little informal study to talk to
people different ages and people in
restaurants and stuff like they said at
what age do people seem to stop wanting
to do new things and get stuck in their
ways or find what they like and stick
with it and there's no one answer in the
cito but he found a tremendous number of
people by about 30 to 35 that's their
music they like sushi or they don't like
sushi you know they kind of they have
their set of stuff that they have going
for them or they don't like and you know
so you could say they get stuck in the
ways you could say they discover what
they like and stick with it you know and
here's an age more of exploration and
variability who knows okay but it's kind
of interesting the older you get the
more consistent you get and you know
this is this flexibility it's just chaos
you know you could look at it either way
there's no real answer okay what people
have looked at these scores and asked
whether things like do they vary with
age and gender so for example these
broken lines are sorry neuroticism which
is a funny label it really means
neuroticism is the bad side of its
stability is the good side of it you
could also say to stable could be boring
and inert you could real able these
things pretty much but you know on
average you know women scores a little
bit less stable than men a little bit
more outgoing a little bit by age you
gets a few trends this will not surprise
you actually
so for a for sorry
neuroticism against stability that
darkness ISM decreases with age people
get more stable and get more
conscientious as they get older you kind
of expect that you people get more used
to their habits and more stuck in their
ways that we would call stability okay
so so let's ask for people who score
high or low on these measures what do
they go with so for these five
fundamental personality measures so
people who score highly on the
neuroticism scale again these labels are
tricky but that means ranging from very
stable and emotional sense to very
labile they pay more attention to
threaten the environment more stressed
when given a surprise math test have a
higher divorce rate more susceptible to
depression and anxiety at the very very
very highest scores of neuroticism it's
a big risk for for depression and
anxiety
and one of the deep questions always is
to what extent are what we call
psychiatric labels extremes of
personality or something beyond
personality this is a much deeper issue
than you think we'll come back to it in
psychiatry because you know some people
say there's no such thing for example a
social anxiety disorder that's a recent
invention for what people used to call
shyness all right I don't think that's
right mostly okay but this debate goes
on because it's there's not a sharp
boundary between being a little shy and
so shy that you don't leave your house
to meet people I mean that's kind of an
extreme but most people you know or
they're not it's not one person is here
and the next person's here there's
people all along a continuum where you
draw the line it is a challenging issue
highly extroverted people versus highly
introverted that sort of shyness are not
going this this will be a big surprise
highly extroverted people by these
personality measures attend more parties
they're more popular they're identified
as leaders in college they live with and
work with more people they're less
disturbed by sudden loud sounds or
intense stimuli you can do experiments
you know in a laboratory and get these
differences this will none of these are
surprising they're just telling you
there's something correct about these
personality measures highly agreeable
people are more willing to lend money
have higher high school grades and a
fewer arrests as adults but the cool
thing is not I mean you're not surprised
with the fact that they fill out a
questionnaire
you know sitting at a desk like you do
predicts to some decent extent over the
population whether they'll go to jail or
not that's kind of interesting more
openness to experience you're more
likely to major in the humanities not
awesome okay change careers in midlife
perform better and job training programs
and play a musical instrument
alright but these are massive
statistical things you know because kind
of conversely well you know there's very
interesting relations between musicality
and sort of math and science backgrounds
so that seems to go against this so
these are big averages maybe I think in
some ways the most interesting one for
for practical reasons has turned out to
be conscientiousness and that's like
doing what you're supposed to do more
sexually faithful to spouses higher job
rating smoke less drink less drive more
safely live longer less risk for
Alzheimer's disease spectacularly less
risk okay and also play a musical
instrument I wonder for this yeah yeah
no matter what okay but I'm so the
Alzheimer's disease is kind of
interesting because I you know what we
think is happening and we don't really
know is this so you may know there's
basically one gene now more recently a
couple other genes identify this
significant risk genes for Alzheimer's
but the one powerful well identifying so
called the so called April II gene and
that is a significant risk gene if you
have to to version two if your
homologous for that you have a higher
risk for Alzheimer's but that best known
best characterized gene is a far smaller
risk factor mathematically you know than
being low country interest and we don't
know what that really means right what's
your guess and nobody knows this is just
an empirical finding and it's been
replicated a number of times what's your
guess so conscientious people do what
they're supposed to well all the things
that you're supposed to in the morning
get up and do they do them pretty well
right you know right you know make your
bed do your laundry regularly brush your
teeth regularly have your medical
appointments regularly you know eat well
exercise approp all the things that
everybody tells you is good for you
conscientious people are more likely to
do
yeah it's something like that yeah a
pipeline analogy if you keep flushing it
regularly instead of clogging it up with
bad things that are bad for you wherever
I mean we don't really in the end there
has to be a biological mechanism and the
other has to be but maybe it's a
lifetime of doing healthy things and
they add up enough day-in day-out month
in month out year in year out that they
somehow in some way either fend off
Alzheimer's disease or diminish its
expression for much longer is that sound
okay but it's it's very it's a very
compelling finding all right so then
there's always a fun question for our
personality and there'll be one big
surprise here I think what one I'll tell
you this is our surprise
Otteman was reminding me that this
lecture there's a parents visiting
weekend which is not today right but a
few years ago I gave this lecture on
that and I came to a conclusion that
parents will find impossible untrue and
you know very disturbing all right get
ready all right here we go so again
we're always curious our personalities
you know whether we're outgoing or not
agreeable or not open or not how much of
that is in our genes at birth how much
is that in our environment in terms of
parental influence of sibling influence
of school and so on so the usual way to
this until we know the true biology of
this our estimates from twin studies and
children reared apart and reared
separately so let me start with the twin
studies so these are identical twins in
green versus dizygotic or fraternal
twins shared environment some shared
genes the difference about this is
thought to be an estimate of heritage of
pure genetic heritability and so you get
a pretty good one extraversion and
openness the most maybe but it
definitely a genetic contribution to
personality that's that's the evidence
from twin studies and it's even
impressive if you do not self-report
questionnaires but behaviors that people
describe activities they do time spent
watching television number of childhood
accidents tendency for marriage and
divorce religious attitudes your balance
between work and leisure you know how
much do you want to be at work all the
time or leisure or what the
ah to be 0.5 that's about half heritable
estimated happiness will come back to
happiness ratings the way people rate
happiness it turns out is if you do a 1
to 7 scale that's the field ok 7 means
happy all the time
one means miserable all the time you
know that's the way happy news research
is done in the last lecture we'll talk
about what people think people do need
to do to be happy but that would they
use that but but one thing we know is
that people tend to have happiness set
points you may know this amongst your
friends or yourselves that is an average
a person will be like very happy or
moderately happy or pretty grumbly most
of the time ok something happens in
their lives that's really good or bad
they'll move a little bit but they'll
slide right back to it right there's
nothing that are worse about one or the
other but it's just people tend to be
pretty sad and the estimates from twin
studies are about half of your chronic
sense of happiness day in day out it
comes from genes is the estimate from
okay so that's a big piece but here's
the kind of stunning thing and in the
next couple of slides I tell you let me
tell you the bottom line and tell you
the evidence yes the empirical evidence
could support a position that parents
and family environments have zero
influence on your personality then the
question is what is the environmental
influence okay because we know it's not
all genetic but wherever it's been
looked at carefully parents and home
environments appear to have by you know
as far as I can see nearly zero
influence on your personality now this
is the thing that drives parents crazy
because as a parent I can tell you from
the moment they're born or even months
before children are born to the moment
you're you're no longer around to take
care of your children you want them you
know to develop the right kind of you
know be a happy person a good person
hopefully something about
conscientiousness to do well in life
right I mean and you're doing every
little thing to encourage that the
comments you make the schools you send
them to the activities you encourage
them to do you want them to have a
personality that will be happy for them
and good for them thriving right I said
to be told that whatever you do doesn't
matter it's kind of a big shock and we
don't really know the depth of this and
it sounds like it's ridiculous but I can
tell you the empirical evidence kind of
supports it okay so for example
for the twin studies it makes no
difference at all for personality
dimensions whether twins are raised
together or raised apart okay so they're
in different families or the same family
doesn't make a difference
all the heritability brings me exactly
the same so you know where are the
environmental factors coming from we
believe there's environmental factors
but we can't spot them and what's
fascinating about these things is that
we as human beings and this is just an
example now always want to understand
who we are is some sort of willful
response to our environments so here are
two identical twins reared apart ah and
they're both super neat okay all right
and here's and neither one of them tells
you well you know it's in my genes what
else were they going to do I mean none
of us mostly think that you know outside
of some you know dire circumstances of
diseases we mostly think ah yeah it's my
choice this morning whether I'm gonna
make my bed or not it's my choice if I
do laundry this year or not right yeah
but the other 50% comes from things like
diet or other things in the environment
it could it what's much in shock is but
even that tends to go by families some
right you know some families just say
you know here's here's a new year's
worth of potato chips good luck alright
another family's going oh my gosh you
didn't need carrots all month long you
know this is right I'm even that tends
to be on average somewhat environmental
right both by Economic Opportunity part
of the world you're in parental
attitudes right yeah but I agree with
you it's gotta be something and maybe we
just don't have the whole story right
but here's two twins telling you why
each of them is very neat okay we the
first one is my mother when I was
growing up this is you know one
household of one twin she always kept a
house perfectly ordered I learned from
her what else could I do okay as I had a
model when my parent she was neat on
neat here's the other twin who's also
very neat the reason is quite simple I'm
reacting to my mother who was a complete
slob okay so it's the complete opposite
stories I'm modeling my parents I'm
rebelling against my parents here but
you know that they they're identical
twins and they end up in the same place
yeah
you
that's another interpretation this is a
good question
you know I'm pretending the explanations
had nothing to do with anything and
you're saying maybe this is personality
think somebody who chooses to model
their parent versus somebody chooses to
rebel against or parent maybe that's the
personality dimension right it could be
would be it's just neatness you know
twins who aren't neat tend to go the
same way in twins who neat tend to go
the same way about 50% of the effect is
in the genes that I don't know I'm not
saying there are things aren't there
it's a bit of a mystery it's a bit of a
shock or so here's here's a couple more
things biological non twin siblings okay
so these are siblings but they're not
twins are far more similar to one
another than adoptive siblings okay
that's okay that's the genetics right
okay because the adopted child is into
the family but here's a shocking one
four personality children are no more
similar to an adoptive sibling than two
too thin our two randomly selected
children so in a household if you have
an adopt a child and a biological child
in that household of sharing the same
environment they are no more similar one
to the other than two random children in
the world okay where is the effect of
the environment where is the parental
effect on the two children in terms of
personality so so people have mounted
this arguments so let me pick another
one you put up your hand if you want to
I'll put up my hand how many people grew
up in a household where one or more
parents spoke you know in a noticeable
accent I mean I did let's let's try this
room okay how many of you who have your
hand up keep your hand up did you keep
your parents accent where's the
environment okay okay and your critical
moments of language development right
you were hearing that accent where is
the environment and you could say well
yeah but there are other people speaking
other things yeah but then zero parental
influence on the way in which you
produce your language so there's a lot
of different things to think as we move
from language to personality but it's
turned out to be surprisingly hard on
some dimensions to show an influence of
parental environment on child
development especially personality yeah
oh yes it's worse than that this is a
very good question it's not only that
they have adoptive parents if they have
another kid in the house there's another
kid in the house they probably go to the
same if they go to church or synagogue
or right or anything like that you know
same school same state you know same
influence of whoever's you know the NAT
NBA basketball champion yeah I mean the
whole list and it all seems to be quick
you can't identify anything in that yeah
yeah
so who diet would influence that who
knows
is that sweat okay well so let me let me
let me separate it from one moment I
think it's some level of analysis all
environmental influences education
parenting everything will have a
biological counterpart in your body and
in your brain right because the
environment has to affect you by how it
changes your body or brain sorry after
you're born ya know it could be added in
there's things that we would methylation
there's there's post there's a lot yeah
it could be all those things but we
who's driving that okay you know who's
what's we're so so that it's not you
know my bet is that we'll discover stuff
about this that we don't grasp yet
there's a it's not the answer is not
going to be parenting makes no
difference okay or environments make no
different or schools make no difference
for personality but we just don't know
how to think about that yes is the best
guess because it's just hard to believe
yeah yeah
iq personality there is a moderate
conscientiousness especially but that
makes sense on average you know and we
certainly know people who are very smart
and very sloppy okay so it's but on
average the more conscientious you are
like you go to school you do your
homework that kinds of stuff there is
there is a positive correlation so so
there's all kinds of one questions
whether how much personality is fixing
your environment so how much is the way
you are from the moment you're born
driving actually the way the teacher
responds to you in school the way the
parent responds to you and so that's why
your personality is already driving your
actual environment right that mean so
because we could say while you're in
school but really how does that you know
do you like the teacher - not like the
teacher
do you like the parent you go you know
you follow them do you oppose them you
know maybe those kinds of things are
happening sometimes people think that
you know that this kind of that your
personality is driving the way your
environment responds to you it might be
done by sibling contrast so you may have
this experience that um it parents and
other people and siblings yourself often
think a fair bit how they are similar or
dissimilar for their own sibling and
they might overdo it okay so the parent
has two kids one kids like one percent
more outgoing and they go that's the
outgoing one okay you know you know one
kid plays five percent more time on the
piano they go oh she's the real musician
and because he plays two more baseball
games a year either athlete or side and
then it starts to snowball that way okay
or all right parent identification could
kids who identify with one parent or and
the other again by their predispositions
you know serves be driving the way the
parents interact with them in a way
that's again driven by the personality
the personalities from the first moment
for one reason or another this drug is
molding the environment around it and
carrying the environmental effect as
well so one of the giant fights in all
of psychology is this and there's not
going to be an answer I'll just say the
debate and to the core of this question
of why do we do the things we do so
personality just psychologists will say
it's these things we just discussed
it's our predispositions to like things
and not like other things in a general
way our personality social psychologists
and we'll spend two lectures in just a
few weeks on so
psychology say people are all kind of
the same it's all about the social
situation we're in probably you know
it's like when these nature-nurture
things probably something about the
situation something about who you are
but let me tell you how some of this
debate has played out so a famous study
that went against the idea of a
personality being constant across
situations and time came from Walter
Mischel and they looked at
conscientiousness and they said okay
some kids score high or low or medium on
conscientiousness now let's look at
nineteen specific behaviors in their
life not their report of how they are or
the parent support of how they are but
things they do that we can measure how
often do they make their bed how often
do they go to class like they should how
often do they complete their homework
assignments how often do they you know
have good class notes when they leave
classes so things you can check yes or
no and they said gee what we notice is
somebody tends to be pretty consistent
about whether they make their bed or not
every morning not perfect but pretty
consistent but that same person may or
may not be so good at completing
homework assignments okay
and that and that person is very
consistent on completing Homa science
may or may not be so good on having neat
class notes so that it's not that people
aren't consistent but it's far more
specific about what they're consistent
about than a big personality dimension
that covers a range of things that ought
to go together so he said this situation
ISM you behave in a certain way in a
certain situation it's not like you have
a personality that moves from situation
to situation and predicts the same route
behavior and here's another example of
how they follow kids in a summer camp
and here's different behaviors from one
child in another child so this is a
child who when a peer approaches how
however a verbally aggressive they are
and so aggression is high this way these
are different situations and you can see
for one child they're aggressive in this
situation when they deal with an adult
and in this situation the other this
other child is aggressive what he or she
deals with a peer so if you were to say
there's an aggressive thing about people
they're aggressive or they're not well
this person's aggressive would appear
and this person is aggressive
specifically with an adult
so is aggressiveness a personality thing
or situation by situation by situation
in the movies you see all the time if
you watch The Sopranos or many movies
it's not uncommon to had the crime
figure be really kind of nice with his
family and really brutal with a
competing criminal gang right have you
seen that yeah
and that's you know the kind of nice at
home and then they go shoot people in
two seconds notice right yeah if they're
fighting about something so you see that
kind of an idea another thing that
people have looked at thats related to
personalities temperament it's a little
bit so it's an innate biologically based
propensity to engage in certain style
behavior is broader than a trait I'll
describe one that's been well studied
but people like it because they think
it's observable so with traits it's hard
to just look at you and say you're
extroverted or you're conscientious you
know I could follow you around all day
maybe have an estimate but sorry but
here they like temperaments are um
broader than traits and you can see in
terms of people's sociability emotional
emotionality and activity level you can
just follow them and see them behave in
certain ways so let's think about the
temperament of shyness so the way these
studies were done at Harvard was that
some babies even at six weeks are more
reactive to make sudden noises they're
more fussy about 20% of children could
be that way they make a noise or
something and they cry they get
disturbed they're unhappy and so he
called those children hi reactive or
inhibited babies those two terms for the
same idea versus low reactive once who
are very disturbed by the environment
and once they were like you know no big
deal okay and the ones who were
inhibited babies cried more they were
distressed more they showed more
activity faster heart rates higher
levels of cortisol and they even have
they could measure this in some cases
faster heart rates in the womb even
before they were born
okay their hearts were racing right so
all it is that one last little thing and
the idea that maybe their sympathetic
nervous system is easily aroused seeks
less arousing situations and it's
inhibited because they're already
internally so aroused they want calm so
there's going to be a surprise in the
story but as we go in terms of thinking
about shyness and you can measure these
at 2 months or 4 months with the
very simple little things you do with
babies to see how they respond to some
noise and to a decent extent it predicts
shyness and later childhood in adulthood
about a quarter of the children who look
pretty inhibited aren't shy but about
75% who look pretty inhibited end up shy
so that's a pretty good prediction from
a two-month-old to a young adults about
75% of these children who look pretty
shy at two months and of course they're
not shy in a group that is responding to
noises right end up being kind of shy as
adults and they studied these four until
age 21 and again and start with several
outcomes specifically things like let's
pick one mmm crime how often get in
crime children who are well controlled
don't get so much into crime children
who had 21 had poor control at age three
are more likely to get into trouble so
as if these temperament factors in early
early childhood already risk factors for
doing better or worse in the world
another one that people enjoy studying
this is more sensation-seeking you know
the bungee jumpers the people who like
to parachute the kinds of people the
people who enjoy the thrill of
activities novel high stimulation
situations statistically they have more
fun probably in some ways they're more
likely to dive they're more likely to
drive fast or more likely to have drug
and alcohol use and more likely to send
flame emails listen to punk music and
have driving accidents so it's an
interesting mix of you know enjoyment in
trouble right and there's some evidence
they have lower levels of something in
the blood that may be a measure of
something that lets dopamine last longer
in the synapse in your brain dopamine is
the reward neurotransmitter so you could
imagine that I'm you know if reward
hangs around longer maybe you're more
drawn towards instantly rewarding things
another sort of I think did a
2-dimensional classification of
personality again one dimension that
they focused on was this in tribution
two extraversion or stable to unstable
this is neuroticism or introversion
extroversion in the big five but there's
some interesting turns
this here's the interesting turn I
mentioned it let me tell you one more
time because when you it's
counterintuitive it's the opposite of
what you think in terms of what people
have found so we think of extroverts as
people you know go to parties are very
talkative very outgoing run around and
have a you know social time and
introverts is more likely to be shy
quiet withdrawn right there's the
definitions of the words but what people
have found in a variety of studies this
is that extroverts di when people are
less easily aroused so it's as if they
seek stimulation it's as if their
internal arousal is low and they want
things that are stimulating an
environment to push up their internal
arousal right introverts are the
opposite around introverts are aroused
already and it's as if they seek
environments that are quiet so their
arousal is not pushed above some level
of discomfort so intuitively you might
think extroverts are more aroused
internally because it is your first but
the thought is that extroverts are
actually seeking arousal okay because
they're a little lower inside introverts
already feeling pretty aroused so they
don't need more bungee jumping
they're already there they're already
feeling like they're bungee jumping okay
so and they're all seeking the sort of
optimal level of arousal so for example
extroverts do better in noisy settings
they can take the extra stuff they don't
mind it right introverts are more
sensitive to pain and they salivate more
to lemon juice they're already kind of
revved up okay is Authority internally
so here's one advantage in the course
but and this is almost as practical
constantly of private you could think
about this for your own test taking a
three-way interaction okay is this three
factors at all interact with one another
in performance and it involves situation
and personality so here we go so the
three factors aren't whether you're
introverted or extroverted whether
you're taking a test a GRE kind of a
test in the morning or the afternoon and
whether you drank a cup of coffee before
the test or not three different things
floating around and here's what people
have found in several times in
experiments when you're taking a test
here's the upshot of these studies if
you're introverted and the test is in
the morning test is in the evening or
late afternoon or evening drink coffee
if you're outgoing drink coffee in the
morning now I'll tell you the logic of
this
okay all right so here's the idea
many studies have shown and you may know
this if you think about people you know
yourself on average introverts are most
aroused in the morning they tend to be
get up early in the morning and get
their day going people maybe because
they didn't party deep into the previous
night okay so I mean there's a lot of
cause and effect it's really hard to
plot in all of this okay
but introverts are more aroused in the
morning and less in the evening it's the
average the kind of people are get up
early in the morning go do their stuff
and the evening they want to you know
mellow down and maybe not go to sleep so
late extroverts are more aroused in the
evening and less in the morning then
this is on average and this has been
found a number of times so again you can
imagine if you're taking a test
if you're under aroused you could use
the coffee to perk you up if you're over
aroused the coffee is going to make you
jittery and push you over so depending
on the time of day you're going to be
one state or the other depending on kind
of person all you have does that make
sense of these three things come
together like that in the famous
yerkes-dodson law of performance which
is this and this is you know observed in
many years
here's arousal how aroused you are super
aroused super nervous shaky so are so
sleepy you you're about to crash out
somewhere in the middle usually goes
with best performance okay because this
is too much and this is too little you
know that if you're too nervous you
don't tend to perform well if you're too
kind of out of it you don't perform well
somewhere in the middle is just right so
here's extroverts you know for example
in the morning they're pretty low on
this they could use some coffee to move
to optimal here's introverts in the
morning they're ready ready to go I'm
ready to go we're ready to go the last
thing is more coffee - oh now um you
know I hope it's not a bubble test right
because my hands are shaking okay so uh
so three things the kind of personal IR
the time of day and you know whether
you're drinking coffee helps you to move
to this middle position or not does that
make sense okay so that's three
different factors sort of adding up to
to optimize performance or not okay
lastly I've had to talk a little bit
about some things we know about brain
correlates of personality and in some
areas these brain things are more
informative at a broad level because
sometimes people will say well
personally out it's all this
checkbox' tough is it even relevant to
anything biological now if it's relevant
to behavior it's relevant to biology
right behavior is biology or biology is
behavior right is it we're not going to
get one relative to the other but still
until recently people couldn't measure
this so these are pictures of not of
brain functions of a task turning on
will see pictures of those in a moment
this is measurement of brain structure
measurement of brain structure and
specifically thickness of cortex so what
you're seeing as a statistic here which
is the more extroverted you are the
thicker your cortex is here the more
conscientious the thicker your cortex
here the more neurotic the thicker your
cortex here and so on so it's not we
don't understand these deeply but we do
see you know physically measurable
correlates of these personality
dimensions so that's physical brain
structure let's talk about some function
thing this is a slide you saw before
that in the amygdala the more
emotionally intense something is the
more the response the more neutral it is
too less the response here's a pot you
know positive happy picture right I'm
going to show you a neutral picture that
I'm going to show you now the bad
picture don't look if you don't want to
see it again so when you saw before
close your eyes for a moment bad picture
okay here we go now you can all look
okay so people are introverted or
extroverted so you know extroverts are
sociable talkative introverts are on
average more reserved or quiet
extroverts report more positive
experiences more susceptible to
positives and mood induction lots of
evidence for some differences among them
so imagine a study where you show people
positive and negative slides again you
know people will say well if I'm you
know on a diet this is really negative
or something or but you know but I don't
you know you have people rate them but
on average these are negative and
herbage these are positive you measure
their personality and here's what you
find in the amygdala the more
extroverted they are the more their
amygdala response to positive things the
more introverted they are the more
response to negative things so here's
exactly what we mean by personality
serve instantiated in one example and
it's not the only symbol what do we mean
by personality we mean there's a
constant situation
pretend a party you go to you know a
party deep in my memory remember parties
I went to the music is playing and
there's sticky beer on the floor and you
know there's people you know and a lot
of people you don't know right so who
walks in the door and thinks this is
awesome the extrovert right who walks in
the door and things collide in my friend
dragged me do this I could be doing
something good like chess at home right
okay yeah okay so now identical
situation different but that's true of
so many things and preferences as life
that's almost what we mean by
personality right who likes what
situations people activities so for
extraversion here's the amygdala going a
positive things will be they notice sort
of speaking they're in their amygdala
the positivity of the environment
they're drawn to things for the cpo
here's the introverts going Danger
Danger okay everybody see the same set
of slides but people are drawn to the
positive or the negative aspects of this
and you could say it's one better the
worse will no avoiding dangerous thinks
is a good idea you know enjoying
positive thinks is a good idea not one
is not better than the other they're
just different you're tuned to different
rewards in life and this is one example
of that how about a smiling face who
thinks a smiling face is an invitation
to go over and meet somebody new the
introvert of the extrovert help me on
this okay who think is modeling faces
pressure do I go over are they smiling
at me right or I'm gonna go over and
another nun that gonna like me exist
they like me now right I mean I should
tell you I I was quite only in my
teaching mode do I appear extroverted
okay but I definitely was an introvert
in high school in college so if I make
fun of introverts I'm making fun of
myself so here's a response to a fearful
faces and we talked about that before
response in the amygdala regardless of
personality but now when we talk about
the response in the amygdala for happy
faces big response if you're extroverted
little response if you're introverted
because a happy face is like compelling
cool wonderful for the extrovert ah not
as not as enticing for the introvert
okay so again the way we might imagine
how do individual differences in
personality play out they play out that
some things are beguiling wonderful and
other things not so much and the
pending on your personality that can
vary so these are the children who were
studied from ages of two and four months
who were shy in temperament and they
compared them to the uninhibited
inhibited in orange sari and they
compared them to the most uninhibited
they take the extremes but it's a very
rare thing when you have a behavioral
assessment of a child in their infancy
and then you bring image them about
twenty years later when they're grown up
so now you're making this out twenty
years of your life story and again in
the amygdala what they find is this if
you look at the people who are
uninhibited the either here's a novel
face they see for the first time in the
scanner or a face they see many times
and there's not much difference for the
people who are inhibited you see a much
bigger amygdala response to the novel
face well this is exactly what you might
intuitively think shyness would be about
if you're a shy person you know somebody
well I think a lot of shyness disappears
but where shyness shows the most is a
face that you don't know a new person
you haven't met and maybe you're not so
comfortable with them yet so it's
exactly the pattern you might expect
that it doesn't matter too much for an
extrovert a new face a familiar face
from the made familiar in the experiment
not somebody you really know it doesn't
make much of a difference for the person
who's inhibited much more responds to
the face they see for the first time
only as opposed to a face they've grown
familiar with a couple more examples
along this line
here's another scale there's an infinite
number of them the spielberger state and
trade anxiety so state and trait right
so they ask you this is just a reminder
of that how do you feel right now that
would be your state right now do I feel
at ease do I feel upset and in general
how do you feel at ease or upset so this
is day-in day-out this is right now
we're going to focus on the trait how
you tell it how you say you feel the
day-in day-out and now they're going to
show you faces of people who are shown
in full view or who are shown in a
subliminal masked version where a fear
of neutral face is followed by another
face this is the critical phase so you
see a face that you see pretty well or
you see a face that's presented under
circumstances where you can't tell
what the face was okay and first they
say what happens if we show you the
regular face that you see perfectly well
it makes much of a difference here's the
amygdala response to a fearful face
you've seen this now multiple times but
kind of interesting you get a smaller
response to the amygdala and it's driven
by how anxious you report yourself to be
on a regular basis so the interpretation
is this if you see a fearful face you
louts a fearful face I know it's a
fearful face we're all the same
if you subliminally present it you have
an unknown source of danger what we
intuitively imagine anxiety is is
feeling danger or threat in your
environment more than is helpful more
than is comfortable okay and you don't
even know exactly why it's not entirely
rational when you're anxious in that way
and so what happens is the more anxious
you are the more these subliminal phases
drive an amygdala response and you don't
have control over that because you don't
know what happened because it was
subliminally presented does that make
sense okay when it's clear everybody
knows what to do it's just a face I'm
not that scary but what it's an unknown
source of a bit of unease the more
chronically anxious you are the more the
brain is responding or we might say the
bigger the brain response is the basis
perhaps of the chronic unease
so we talked also before about the
amygdala being important for recognizing
fearful expressions and and then I want
to two last examples
how about genetic influences so we we
know genes are a big part of the story
but how big a part of the story so again
we talked about single nucleotide
polymorphisms common genetic variants
and here's one that involves a serotonin
transporter in the amygdala there's a
short or long allele you can so you know
when it will have two of these all of us
the short allele is weakly correlated
with anxiety traits all this genetic
stuff is pretty weak at the moment for
reasons that are not well understood
I'm only presenting you ones that have
been at least replicated once but
there's practically every genetic
example I'm going to show you there's
been non confirmations as well we don't
know why this is the genes are just so
far away from complex human behaviors is
probably the answer
but what has been replicated a number of
times is this if they show you fearful
faces and you have the short allele the
one that's slightly associate with
anxiety this is the difference between
people with the long goalie on the
shorter leave a much more powerful
response to fearful faces if you have
the shorter allele so a single gene can
be correlated with a more potent
response to a sort of threat stimulus
and again that goes with their sense of
anxiety and when we might call a a
less-than-desirable response to threat
in the environment so here's the last
two slides and I but it's it's the dream
we all have in understanding people and
actually all animals on the face of this
planet but people most of all if you're
curious about people which is what is
the interaction between the genes were
born with and the life we lead and how
does that end up with us being us all
right and it's incredibly hard to study
that because everybody says in biology
and neuroscience we know it's a gene by
experience interaction that you know the
genes will make you good strong in some
circumstances and vulnerable and others
but it's very hard to specify that the
genes have been hard to identify and we
can't put people into experiments we
can't say you know what's like two
identical twins and we'll put one into
some horrible household full of stress
and horribleness and went into a
delightful household and then see them
at 20 and see what happened okay we're
just not allowed to do that right so we
can't experiment on the environment and
we don't the genes are poorly understood
very poorly understood in relation to
two basic human behaviors but there's a
study from Casspi that you know is a
glimpse of where we think the field
might be going but I'm going to warn you
that this has not always been replicated
it's somewhat rough it's been replicated
some times but not other times so it's a
warrant as an asterisk but it's it's
still a finding that's really quite
striking if it turns out to be roughly
correct so again this is this
polymorphism of the same gene that's
associated with anxiety and what they
did in a very large sample in New
Zealand was catalogue stressful life
events ages 21 to 26 job how you do it
whether you have a job or not your
salary decent housing terrible housing
good health bad health happy
relationships no relations
it's terrible relationships people are
filling out forms telling you about the
stresses in their life and then they
also have information about childhood
maltreatment some of these children it's
very sadly when they were younger we're
treated very poorly they were abused in
some way or another we're in very
terrible circumstances and some not so
they're going to look at stressful
events in childhood and adulthood and
sort them out by the allele the
individuals have the gene version and
what they find is enough showing a graph
in a moment more depression and
suicidality in response to stressful
events given them if you have the short
version of the allele the short version
we just said is the one that seems to
drive a bigger anxiety response to
fearful faces in the amygdala okay so it
seems first pass to be a gene that's
associated with responding in a more
anxious way to environmental stress
threat and bad things so here's a couple
of graphs I'll just do a couple with you
here's the probability of major
depression if you've had no maltreatment
as a child
if you've probably had some or you've
had documented horrible maltreatment as
a child and what you can see if you have
the long version this is this lines here
the long version of this allele no
difference it's as if it's as if if you
happen to be born in a biological
lottery that we all participate in at
birth with these version of these genes
and maybe many other genes that are part
of the story list they just measure this
one that it doesn't matter how people
whether you live in a nice supportive
environment or a brutalizing horrible
one your probability of depression is
about the same it's a protective gene
for stresses of life that are visited
upon you if you have the office of the
short version look the worse the
environment you double your chances of
depression it's as if you're born with a
gene that if you're given a terrible
environment this is exactly interaction
right then you're very susceptible to
that and you see the same thing you know
the same rough pattern all of them that
the individuals who have this version of
the gene seem to be relatively imper
to environmental stressors the ones born
with this version of the gene are
terribly so you know if this person is
born with this version of the gene but
happens to be a nice supportive
household no problem right okay but if
they happen to be born into a household
where they experience sadly severe
maltreatment big problem and so this is
exactly what we imagine if we understood
any depth what people are about and they
you know the genetic potentiation is
you're born with what's easy for you or
hard for you by genes and the world
you're handed as an infant not under
your control but the environment you're
given supportive or threatening right
how those two things play out and it
sort of duet you know putting you making
you safe or putting you at risk you know
that's exactly what we've done would
deeply understand the biology and the
psychology of human life so this is a
kind of thought he gets a lot of
attention because if we had it exactly
right which we don't yet we would
understand something really deep about
people and vulnerability and
environments
you